cameras are everywhere there are cameras
at intersections cameras and convenience
stores cameras in our computers or
phones our workplaces there's even
better camera in katie couric this is
clean as Alyssa this is a perfectly
normal
but there is one group of people so
powerful and so secretive that they've
thwarted virtually every attempt to
capture them on film gladden bizarre
costumes from the past and speaking a
language that is as unintelligible as it
is unwieldy this insular Society of
elders meets in a temple just steps away
from the United States Catholic the
power unquestioned the rulings final
their secrecy supreme what is the
Supreme Court hiding beneath their robes
that they continue to say no to cameras
in the courtroom well I could say
quickly that we've been waiting and
waiting and waiting c-span founder Brian
lamb has devoted his life to turning
surveillance cameras on America's power
elites while he can't take credit for
the corec footage he has managed to
infiltrate the legislative and executive
branches of the federal government but
the Supreme Court has stoned him cold
it's like every other institution of
government there's always a time when
they decide when it's right for them
you'd expect Supreme Court justices to
have the best arguments against
transparency but just like the Keeler
decision okaying eminent domain abuse
their logic is as baffling and
embarrassing as their choice of neckwear
the arguments on the other side in the
Supreme Court are one people would worry
because of the symbolic value of the
court that the television would then be
in every courtroom in the country
including all the criminal cases where
you have concerns about witnesses and
jurors and intimidation and so forth
cameras are already in every other
courtroom in the country and judges have
wide discretion to shield certain
testimony and witnesses from public view
and if you're worried about the symbolic
nature of your position you better worry
about the man in the mirror cutouts from
from the full day's proceedings would
appear on the on the evening news it's
called interpretation Justice Scalia we
do it based on written transcripts of
oral arguments all the time regular
appearances on TV would mean significant
changes in the way my colleagues could
conduct their lives
my anonymity is already gone quick
advice justice if you're worried about
your anonymity don't take a public
service job and don't go rving with 60
minutes you know it's really a very
simple thing it's in a government
institution that's funded by the
American taxpayers the individuals that
work there all get paid for by the
taxpayer and the decisions aren't even
reached in that courtroom their reached
behind closed doors which we're not
asking to do faced with the manifest
failure of their arguments they resort
to the last refuge of middle-aged
married men begging and pleading please
don't introduce this into our inter
collegial deliberations we don't want it
thankfully things may be looking up as
older judges retire it's better to be
sure than sorry okay a new younger crop
of free-thinking swinging justices take
their place I have had positive
experiences with cameras I do things
that I respect her it would be a good
thing from many perspectives well maybe
not from all perspectives for you to put
the scope in yeah pitches yeah we're
doing the examiner oh really
for reason TV I'm Nicholas
you